Benvenuti nella nostra Ocean Villa qui
alle Maldive all'ingresso troviamo
questa lastra di vetro dalla quale
possiamo vedere il mare questo è il
soggiorno che faccia direttamente sulla
piscina ma andiamo per step partiamo dal
bagno principale che ha sia la vasca che
la doccia qui dietro c'è anche una
cabina armadio dove abbiamo stipato
tutte le cose che c'erano in giro quindi
per ovvie ragioni non ve la farò vedere
salendo al piano superiore troviamo la
zona notte con questo letto comodissimo
e questa super vista anche qui sopra
abbiamo un bagno sempre con doccia e qui
arriva la Chicca della villa perché
uscendo dalla doccia possiamo accedere
direttamente a questo fantastico scivolo
che ci porta dritti al mare scendiamo di
nuovo al piano inferiore attraverso
questa scaletta chiocciola qui troviamo
la piscina sfioro profondo 1,20 questa
zona con una scaletta per accedere
direttamente al mare e poi la parte che
mi piace di più con questi divani pieni
di cuscini e questa rete sul mare
stupenda torniamo all'interno Dove
troviamo il terzo e ultimo bagno e il
secondo letto Infine abbiamo la zona bar
con frigobar e Cantinetta dei vini il
tour della villa è finito qui Fatemi
sapere se vi è piaciuta baci